une contestation qui annonce la fin pour
un yb et cas selon ban cissé porte
parole du conseil supérieur de la
diaspora malienne écoutez le aujourd'hui
vous avez là et raso de majorité de la
population qui reprochent un certain
l'assistanat laxisme il ya eu toute
cette crise est due après les élections
législatives
il a été plus de sécurité entre
guillemets nommé et non élu
ce qui est demandé clairement c'est par
les manifestants c'est la démission du
président une carte et à la dissolution
de l'assemblée nationale
romagné le coq la cour constitionnelle
parce que c'est là qu'au conditionnel
cas programme qui a proclamé ce genre de
résultat qui aujourd'hui amène la rue à
tandil prêté pendant la république et
aujourd'hui on s'en va on va tout droit
vers une insurrection une insurrection
populaire
j'ai rarement vu une pub le mans mais
aussi déterminés et jusqu'au boutiste